[Music]
joining me now is Senator Tim Scott 2024
GOP Presidential candidate haven't him
had I don't think we've had you on the
angle before Senator so it's great to
see you thank you um what do you make of
the administration's continued um
efforts to kind of downplay what Iran
has done with Hamas it makes them
complicit you think about the fact that
his weakness invited the attacks without
any question his negotiations of $6
billion he gave to Iran helped to fund
the attacks in his first statements out
of the administration was telling them
to refrain from responding that is
insanity but it's also makes Biden
complicit with the attacks I can't say
it more clearly I am very concerned that
this is actually a mass plan on the
radical left when you think about our
Southern border wide open insecure and
unsafe you think about the funding that
they send over to Iran you put all that
together what do you see you see the
squad out there with with their
anti-Semitism you see all the strategies
coming together for one purpose the
purpose is power there is something
sinister of nature in the midst of all
of this well what do you think about
Biden uh planning to go to China after
they've had this parade of top officials
they surveil us with the balloons
they're building a military surveillance
station in Cuba uh obviously continue to
uh spy on us surveil us hack our emails
weager persecution the list goes on and
on they want to take Taiwan they want to
keep building their Island and yet we go
and bow and scrape to China Time After
Time what about that c well Janet Yellen
went to to China said well we have no
problems we we want to just get along
and Joe Biden is singing Kumbaya that is
a wrong strategy if Joe Biden is
reelected what do you think our policy
toward China will ultimately become
total capitulation socialism is their
strategy and looking at the Communist
Chinese party it is going to be
devastating to our economy devastating
to our kids they're buying our farmlands
they're spying on on our basis we have
to have a strong president who stands
toe-to-toe with President she it is not
the strength of China it is the weakness
of Joe Biden now Senator Scott in South
Carolina obviously you and Nikki Haley
are are among the most popular people in
the state but Donald Trump is leading by
a lot I'm not sure if we have the
numbers up but but he's leaving by you
know I don't know 30 points in in South
Carolina why is that listen I think
people are sick and tired of watching
the Department of Justice lose their
blindfold and so you're seeing this kind
of response and reaction to what is in
fact the doj Hunts Republicans and
protects Democrats starting with the
Biden family that actually has been
helpful to the president you see someone
listen I'm a guy from the south so I
appreciate Law And Justice when you see
even my political opponents being hunted
by this department of justice so you
think they're supporting Trump because
the doj and FBI are going after him not
not policy I think no no no I think I
think I think the the most immediate
issue is for indictments you know that's
unfair certainly 2017 2020 I wrote the
text if he asked you to be his vice
president would you say yes I'm running
to be president of the United States I
know you are everybody says that I
actually mean it though I know you are
but would you if if it doesn't come out
I can't think of losing I've got to
think of winning that's why you're one
of the most popular hosts on TV you only
think about one thing and that's one
I've got to think about one thing is
making sure that the American dream is a
for the Next Generation well and I think
this test of the country right now with
what we're seeing happening in Israel
and the response of this country and our
Southern border devastating will we ever
learn will we ever we better learn quick
fast in a hurry Senator don't be a
stranger great to see you thanks so much
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else